à quelques kilomètres des pyramides un
archéologue français s'apprête à faire
une découverte exceptionnelle
[Musique]
viennent de dégager des murs de briques
qui délimitent un puit vertical pour
l'instant totalement rempli de sable
sous nos pieds ça peut descendre à 4 5 6
je sais pas combien de mètres donc pour
l'instant je peux seulement imaginer
et quand on verra ce que c'est mais là
on va dire voilà
il y a quelque chose où il y a pas
ce Français d'origine bulgare s'appelle
Vassil de Bref
cela fait 15 ans qu'il fouille le désert
à la recherche de tombeau de l'ancienne
Égypte
mais des découvertes comme celles
d'aujourd'hui l'archéologue les comptes
sur les doigts d'une main car ce puits
est particulièrement spectaculaire il
descend sur 10 mètres de profondeur au
cœur du désert
soudain au fond une cavité apparaît
voilà ce qu'espérait facile l'entrée
d'une tombe fermée depuis l'Antiquité
[Applaudissements]
pour l'instant je vois pas grand-chose
[Musique]
Vassil vient de dégager l'entrée d'un
caveau funéraire dont le plafond s'étend
parti effondré d'après leur style ses
motifs ont été peints plus de 2000 ans
avant Jésus-Christ maintenant on peut
crever là pour vous c'est un grand
moment ah oui oui parce que c'est pour
la première fois que ce site là on
trouve une chambre décorée en bas
les couleurs sont quasiment intactes
après plus de 4000 nerfs sous le sable
allez les gars
mais pour découvrir le contenu de la
tombe il va falloir patienter
on va fermer avec des blocs pour que des
voleurs puissent pas descendre et aller
casser les blocs sur l'intérieur voilà
on sécurise provisoirement c'est
frustrant mais vas-y il n'a pas d'autre
choix que de sceller la tombe pour la
nuit
[Musique]
son nom ainsi que celui d'abdu
l'inspecteur égyptien responsable de la
fouille sont inscrits sur le mur qui
ferme l'accès à la découverte
les voleurs vont me dire j'ai peur oui
c'est Abdou c'est les jours je peux pas
le toucher parce que il l'a déjà vu
s'il voit mon nom c'est fini il s'en va
[Musique]
cap sur une destination qui regorge de
trésors et où les archéologues du monde
entier ne cessent de faire des
trouvailles comme il y a deux mois cette
égyptologue britannique qui annonce
avoir découvert un passage secret dans
la tombe de Toutankhamon il semble que
l'une de ses entrées mène à la tombe de
la reine Néfertiti
facile l'archéologue français explore
les mystères des tombeaux oubliés
lui aussi espère bientôt découvrir un
caveau inviolé depuis l'Antiquité
personne est rentré à l'intérieur ça
peut-être arriver une forme dans une vie
mais depuis la Révolution les trésors de
l'Egypte sont en danger le pillage est
devenu quotidien au pied des pyramides
des voleurs creusent le sol en quête de
fortune la police est débordée
lève-toi et viens avec moi mais pourquoi
parce qu'il y a une fouille clandestine
ici
pour protéger ses antiquités l’égypte
construit un musée ultra sécurisé où
sont actuellement restaurés des pièces
qui n'ont jamais été montrées au public
pour la première fois l'intégralité du
trésor de Toutankhamon sera exposé
l'Egypte tente de mettre ses trésors à
l'abri mais parviendra-t-elle à faire
revenir cet touristes
car sur le Nil les bateaux de croisière
sont aujourd'hui quasiment vides les
rares passagers se frottent les mains on
a l'impression qu'on
est pour ceux qui ont le privilège de
naviguer dans le luxe d'un bateau à
vapeur entièrement d'époque
l'expérience est tout simplement magique
voyage exceptionnel à la recherche des
trésors des pharaons
[Musique]
les pyramides de Gizeh sur les hauteurs
du Caire l'un des paysages les plus
célèbres du monde
pourtant ce matin il n'y a que quelques
dizaines de touristes dont ce petit
groupe de français
franchement il
y a personne on s'attend à avoir une
foule de jantes tout ça de des entrées
des afin d'écones en plus finir et
finalement tu arrives là tu vois
personne tu te dis mais c'est bizarre il
se passe quelque chose du coup ça fait
bizarre mais c'est bien en même temps on
peut faire des photos sans personne il y
a plus de guides que de touristes j'ai
l'impression
devant le Sphinx il y a quatre fois
moins de visiteurs qu'avant la
révolution de janvier 2011 un drame pour
l'Égypte dont le tourisme est l'une des
principales ressources
mais pour les voyageurs c'est une
aubaine car en ce moment les prix sont
cassés et c'est ce qui a décidé les
Français de ce groupe à franchir le pas
et à s'offrir le voyage de leurs rêves
l’acheter petit j'ai toujours été
fasciné par par les pharaons et tout ça
enfin toute la civilisation
de ce pays après c'était vraiment pas
très cher aussi 800 euros la semaine
tout compris si les touristes sont rares
c'est qu'aujourd'hui l'Egypte fait peur
il faut dire que l'atmosphère y est un
peu particulière
aux pyramides impossible de ne pas voir
les sentinelles en tenue de combat où
les patrouilles à dos de chameau
aujourd'hui 300 policiers sécurisent le
site en permanence
même les chameliers qui promènent les
touristes sont systématiquement
fouillées et passés au détecteur de
métaux ainsi que leurs montures
avant d'être autorisé à rentrer dans le
périmètre
pour leur premier voyage en Egypte Gaby
et Rebecca deux étudiantes venus de
Melbourne en Australie ne s’attendait
pas de telle mesure de sécurité
les sacs à l'intérieur de la machine
s'il vous plaît un par un et bienvenue
en Égypte
et Gaby et Rebecca n'ont pas tout
remarqué notamment ce policier en civil
armé d'un pistolet mitrailleur qui ne
quitte pas leur groupe d'une semaine
il a pour consigne de rester discret
pour ne pas affoler les touristes
ça vous fait quoi d'avoir un homme qui
vous suit partout avec une mitraillette
sous sa veste il y a un homme
personne ne nous en a parlé où il est ce
dingue il est juste là salut l'ami
bonjour vous n'étiez pas en train de
prendre des photos on pensait que vous
étiez un gars d'ici non non il est
policier vous êtes officier de police
bah oui il était avec nous dans le bus
ah bon je pensais que les policiers
c'était les gars habillés en blanc je
n'avais vraiment rien remarqué bon
maintenant sans vraiment sécurité a
carrément
[Rires]
à quelques kilomètres des pyramides
[Musique]
au sud du Caire
comme tous les jours
l'egypteologue vacille de bref prend la
route de son chantier
[Musique]
facile et l'un des rares archéologues à
avoir poursuivi son travail même au pire
moment de la révolution égyptienne
pour rejoindre sa fouille il longe la
vallée d'une île sur 20 km
jusqu'au site de Saqqara un cimetière
antique situé dans le désert
saqara c'est les très très grand
cimetière de la capitale égyptienne si
on peut comparer avec la France avec
Paris c'est comme père la chaise
la capitale des pharaons même fils était
situé ici à l'emplacement de cette vaste
palmeraie aujourd'hui il n'en reste
presque rien
quant à Sakara sans doute le site le
plus sacré de l'histoire du pays il se
trouvait juste en face en surplomb sur
une bande de déserts ou furbatit les
premières pyramides d'Égypte
voici le travail à cet endroit depuis
plus de 20 ans et c'est aujourd'hui l'un
des meilleurs connaisseurs de ses
secrets
[Musique]
c'est un droit protégé exceptionnel en
hauteur et c'est pour ça que les rois
ont choisi ici pour se faire enterrer si
on pense égyptien
pharaonique et bien c'est la Drôle plus
près du soleil le soleil c'est leur Dieu
le Dieu créateur donc si on veut
rejoindre si on veut se rapprocher du
soleil c'est là qu'il faut monter
voici à choisi d'installer sa fouille au
sommet d'une colline le point le plus
élevé de tout le site de Saqqara
un chantier ou émerge aujourd'hui du
désert les vestiges de tombeau bâti il y
a plus de 4000 ans des constructions que
les anciens Égyptiens appelaient les
maisons d'éternité
ce matin va-t-il va dégager la tombe
qu'il vient de découvrir à une dizaine
de mètres sous la surface du désert
sous ses ordres une cinquantaine
d'ouvriers s'activent autour du Puy
funéraire mais personne n'est autorisé à
pénétrer dans le tombeau avant
l'archéologue
il faut faire le mois possible de
vibrations parce que à l'intérieur il y
a un linteau qui
sur lequel il y a pas mal de sable donc
il faut pas que ça ça se classe quoi
voilà la structure de la tombe que voici
la mise au jour un puits vertical de 10
mètres de profondeur qui conduit au
caveau fait de blocs de calcaire décorés
à l'intérieur l'archéologue espère
découvrir un sarcophage et peut-être une
momie et des objets funéraires
mais avant cela il va falloir vider la
tombe qui est entièrement remplie de
gravats
impossible pour l'instant de savoir ce
qui se trouve toujours en dessous
bientôt le haut des murs apparaît
malgré le sable les couleurs sont
intactes et les premières inscriptions
livrer rapidement de précieuses
indications
ici on commence à avoir une formule
c'est la formule de France c'est le roi
qui offre une offrande pour les lieux
Anubis qui est le dieu de monification
et c'est au bout seulement de cette
ligne qu'on va peut-être avoir le nom
les titres du personnage qui est
intéressant
voilà il y a d'autres offres qui
apparaissent là ça ce sont les pots les
Jards dans lesquels on mettait les
huiles sans ces huiles en ressuscite pas
ça c'est clair
dans la civilisation égyptienne ce qui
est représenté sur les murs possède un
pouvoir magique ces cuisses de boeuf par
exemple permettent au défunt de
s'alimenter dans l'au-delà
quand on mange la viande on est fort
donc on voudrait bien dans notre vie
être fort même jusqu'aujourd'hui les
gens lui disent en arabe quand on voit
quelqu'un de fort on donne on dit pas
l'épipède il est très fort il dit il
mange de la viande
va s'il pense que c'est peintures ont
environ 4200 ans elles sont pourtant
dans un état de conservation remarquable
on peut même voir les maladresses du
peintre qui les a réalisés
l'archéologue peut à présent se glisser
au fond de la tombe il va tenter d'y
repérer les hiéroglyphes qui indiquent
le nom et la fonction de la personne qui
a été enterrée ici
maintenant on va aller au bout de
l'inscription
prêter lecteur
scribes magicien
je crois que il s'appelle Sabi
ouais il s'appelle Sabi
ce qui veut dire
ma protection quelque chose comme ça
ces personnages viennent de réciter dans
l'histoire parce qu'on vient de
prononcer son nom c'est exactement ce
qu'il cherchait pour eux c'était ça la
résurrection salavi après la mort
imaginez l'importance que c'est est-ce
que quelqu'un va prononcer notre nom en
6000 après notre ère quand on est
aujourd'hui si 4000 ans après c'est 6000
donc personne ne prononcera mon nom
niveau nom ni celui du président de la
République on les connaîtra même pas
alors que nous on vient de prononcer le
nom d'un simple prêtre qui s'est fait
enterrer ici et donc lui en revanche lui
il existe
des gravats se sont accumulés sur ce qui
reste du plafond il faut les retirer
pour éviter l'effondrement
dans les déblais une surprise attend
l'archéologue
des objets apparaissent un petit
couvercle en pierre peinte et une
trouvaille encore plus exceptionnelle je
crois que c'est un statuette
en bois c'est plutôt rare des objets
comme ça parce que pour que ça se
préserve depuis millénaires il faut
un bon endroit bien fermé autrement le
bois pourri et qu'est-ce qu'elle fait là
elle doit pas être là elle doit être en
bas
j'étais derrière comme ça c'est le
plafond ça c'est il faut la place
la tombe a donc été pillée dans
l'Antiquité mais coup de chance les
voleurs ont abandonné plusieurs objets
fais un petit peu en calcaire une pièce
toute simple dont la valeur se compte
pourtant en milliers d'euros tous ces
objets étaient censés aider le défunt à
revivre après la mort si sont des vase
simulacre c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont juste
une fonction
qui mais il représente 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
jarre là c'est beaucoup plus petit mais
imaginons que c'est déjà avec de la
bière avec des liquides avec des huiles
avec des choses comme ça
quant à la statue elle représente sans
doute le propriétaire de la tombe
mets le haut du corps n'a pas résisté
malheureusement elle est top pourrie on
peut pas la bouger
si on la bouge et part en poussière oui
la tête n'existe plus on est là-bas du
corps est parfait et la tête n'existe
plus
peu importe que la statuette ne soit pas
entière il faut sauver ce qui peut
encore l'être Ali le restaurateur de la
mission est appelé pour préserver ce
petit bout de bois sculpté il y a plus
de 4000 ans
[Musique]
c'est un produit à la base de cellulose
c'est pour le bois pour consolider le
bois
[Musique]
soit elle est pourri avec le temps parce
qu'elle était dans le sable et c'est pas
bien conservé soit les voleurs qui sont
passés par ici exactement
l'ont peut-être décapité ils ont enlevé
les yeux tout ça parce qu'il voulait pas
se faire reconnaître ils avaient peur
quand ils veulent quelque chose que le
propriétaire de la tombe celui qui va
réciter qui a déjà peut-être ressuscité
qu'il voit et qu'il dénonce qu'il
dénonce Osiris comme ça ce voleur lui
qui espère aussi réciter un jour il
espère aussi effacer comme un bon
quelqu'un de très bien mais comme ça
notre Sabi va lui dire mais non celui-là
voulait ma tombe donc celui-là il peut
pas ressusciter
la statue même très abîmée est une
indication des objets qui se trouvaient
dans la tombe au moment de l'enterrement
pour l'archéologue c'est donc un
témoignage très précieux
dernière étape voici les ses ouvriers
vide le reste de la tombe ils ont encore
l'espoir de trouver les vestiges du
prêtre Sabi peut être des restes de sa
momie ou de son sarcophage
mais malheureusement
rien n'a échappé au pire
donc là les choses sont claires ça a été
un terrain violet
ce qui trouve le crâne sous la pierre
fracassée
rien
ce qui reste de lui
bien que la tombe était pillée les
trouvailles d'aujourd'hui sont
exceptionnels
ce caveau entièrement peint va rejoindre
le tableau de chasse de facile sur le
plateau de Saqqara
les autres trésors qu'il a découvert se
trouvent à quelques mètres de la fouille
sous la surface du désert dans un lieu
fermé à la visite et très sécurisé
il y a 15 ans lorsqu'il a commencé à
creuser vacille a eu la chance du
débutant
on est ici avec la première tombe qu'on
a découvert en 2001 et on est la chance
de tomber tout de suite sur une façade
une façade qui date de l'ancienne empire
l'âge d'or de l'Égypte antique et qui va
le mener à d'autres tombeaux juste à
côté
tous appartiennent à des prêtres des
personnages qui ont passé leur existence
au service du pharaon
facile qui lit les hiéroglyphes comme
une bande dessinée a réussi à rentrer
dans l'intimité de ces personnages
ok si nous avons un prêtre un prêtre
égyptien il était au service d'un
et voilà on est devant sa tombe devant
la façade de cet homme donc c'est sa
porte ici ça porte on rentre et puis la
tombe est derrière il s'appelle pépère
ça veut dire le roi pépé est vivant
c'est un peu comme aujourd'hui si je
vais être bien placé je vais être un bon
bon fonctionnaire de l'État français je
vais m'appeler le président Hollande est
vivant
c'est exactement ça du coup je serais
bien vu ah et lui si exactement ça à
côté c'est sa femme l'aimer bien sûr il
aime son épouse donc il s'appelle
l'aimer oui mais on a un petit problème
parce qu'entre les deux oui une autre
femme et elle elle s'appelle celle qui
rend le cœur vivant ça c'est le cœur ça
c'est celle qui rend le cœur vivant
c'est tout un programme et donc
j'imagine bien sûr c'est une hypothèse
que c'est peut-être sa maîtresse
donc celle qui rend son cœur vivant bien
entendu une plus jeune que son épouse
bien tu sais le rêve de tout le monde et
ce rêve qu'il a dans sa vie terrestre il
veut le transposer il veut que ça
continue de l'autre monde
ces bas-reliefs qui décorent la façade
de la tombe sont inestimables ils figure
parmi les plus anciennes et les plus
belles œuvres découvertes sur le site de
Saqqarah
au fond on a le puits
et c'est là en bas où se trouve la tombe
un puit de 9 mètres de profondeur et un
caveau en calcaire sans aucune
décoration qui était vide au moment de
sa découverte
cette sépulture a été pillée pendant
l'Antiquité
ces tombes sont protégées par un plafond
de métal et par des trappes sécurisées
pour dissuader les voleurs le pillage
c'est aujourd'hui la hantise de Vasil
les objets que l'archéologue vient de
découvrir vont tous être mis en sécurité
la valeur marchande de tous ces objets
ce chiffre en dizaines de milliers
d'euros
ils seront bientôt à l'abri dans les
entrepôts du ministère égyptien des
antiquités
en leurregistre en le photographie comme
ça il est protégé l'objet a une identité
exactement
identité mais aussi il est connu déjà
une fois l'objet numéroté il doit pas
disparaître
parce qu'il essayait il existe
le désert de Saqqara regorge donc de
trésors
mais aussi de pilleurs qui sont prêts à
tout pour les récupérer
tout autour de la fouille Abdou a repéré
de nombreuses traces de leur passage
regardez ce trou
si vous regardez autour de vous vous
allez en trouver partout
les pilleurs viennent et creusent des
trous partout ils sondent et puis il se
déplacent d'un endroit à l'autre vous
voyez ils ont aussi creusé là-bas
à certains endroits il semble même que
les pilleurs est utilisé des bulldozers
regardez ça
d'énormes cratères sont apparues à flanc
de colline
ici dans l'Antiquité on a creusé des
chambres funéraires dans la montagne
les pilleurs de ton sont arrivés ils ont
cassé la roche jusqu'à ce qu'il découvre
ses cavités
jusqu'au tombes ils ont raflé tout ce
qu'il y avait dedans vous voyez tout le
sable qu'ils ont enlevé
d'après Abdou les pilleurs qui ont
creusé ces trous ne seraient autre que
certains habitants du village voisin
situé en contrebas dans la palmeraie
Abdou en veut pour preuve l'extension
sauvage du cimetière local qui a
brusquement envahi le désert en plein
site archéologique en direction des
pyramides
en briques blanches ce sont des tombes
qui ont été construites par certains
habitants du coin après la Révolution
quand c'était le désordre et qu'il n'y
avait plus de police ce ne sont pas des
vrais tombes pour la grande majorité ce
ne sont pas de vrais tombent ils
construisent une pièce un plafond une
porte et quand ils sont à l'intérieur on
peut pas savoir ce qu'ils font ce sont
en fait des clandestine invisibles
depuis l'extérieur
dans les allées du cimetière il y a même
des traces très récentes du passage des
pilleurs
comme ici où ils ont sondé le sol avec
une machine
les gens du peuple ont perdu la tête à
cause des antiquités
ils se disent qu'une petite statuette
qu'ils peuvent mettre dans leur poche
bah leur apporter des millions
en tout cas aujourd'hui en Égypte c'est
ce que tout le monde pense
à Sakara le pillage ne s'arrête pas au
cimetière ou au désert
il peut aussi prendre une forme encore
plus étonnante
[Musique]
ce soir le commissariat de la police des
antiquités de Saqqarah et sur le pied de
guerre
j'ai la mitraillette je sais que
l'extérieur
passe-moi le gilet pare-balles
c'est 20 hommes lourdementarmés doivent
arrêter des pilleurs ils ont été alertés
par un informateur qui a repéré des
activités suspectes dans une maison
située juste au bord du plateau de
saqara
on bloque toutes les issues pour que
personne n'entre ni ne sorte le plus
important c'est la sécurité à
l'extérieur c'est compris ok chef
après quelques minutes de route les
policiers pénètrent dans les ruelles du
village d'aboucir
on sait aujourd'hui que toutes ces
habitations ont été construites sur les
vestiges d'un faubourg de Memphis la
capitale des pharaons de l'ancienne
empire toute fouille y est interdite
la cible des policiers c'est une petite
épicerie de quartier à l'intérieur un
vieil homme est en train de faire sa
prière
est-ce que vous voulez
calme-toi on a un mandat du procureur de
la République je ne suis pas opposé à la
perquisition tu t'appelles bien Mohamed
oui lève-toi et viens avec moi mais
pourquoi parce qu'il y a une fuite
clandestine ici mais c'est pas chez moi
ici si c'est ta maison non monsieur la
maison elle va jusqu'au mur derrière
c'est pas ma maison
c'est bon ça va je veux des policiers
ici il est en état d'arrestation
allez mettez sandales et viens avec nous
l'indicateur qui a prévenu la police
était très bien renseigné c'est dans
l'autre pièce
dans la chambre du fond un puits a été
creusé directement dans le sol de la
maison
attention on recule sous cette planche
il y a un vide
c'est une fouille clandestine très bien
cachée il a mis ce cylindre en métal
pour contenir l'eau tout autour car avec
la pression ça risquait de s'effondrer
mais le chantier a dû s'interrompre à
cause de cette pompe défaillante
d'après nos informations tout au fond il
est arrivé jusqu'à la porte d'un temple
il n'a pas pu continuer parce que la
nappe phréatique s'est infiltrée et sa
pompe est tombée en panne il n'avait pas
les moyens de se payer une deuxième
pompe alors il a proposé à certaines
personnes d'acheter la maison en l'état
pour 20 millions de livres
20 millions de livres soient plus de 2
millions d'euros la fièvre de l'or c'est
emparée des riverains des sites
pharaoniques
ils n'ont rien découvert non ils n'ont
rien sorti grâce à Dieu on a pu les
arrêter à temps
et voilà la preuve que les pilleurs ont
bien trouvé une construction antique ces
pierres de calcaire taillées qui ont été
remontées du puits et qui n'ont rien à
faire dans une région au sous-sol
sableux
dans la pièce voisine la perquisition
continue
ils l'ont transporté ici pour continuer
à fouiller dans la première pièce
de déblais pour voir s'il n'y a pas
d'objets archéologique ou des pierres
qui pourraient nous donner des
informations sur ses vestiges
allez-y je vous rejoins on ne te menote
pas mais ne fait pas d'histoire
c'est une façon humiliante de sortir de
ma maison pour un homme comme moi
on va juste poser deux trois questions
le propriétaire est interpellé ainsi que
son neveu le seul autre homme présent
dans la maison
[Musique]
tous deux risques jusqu'à 3 ans de
prison je ne suis pas un criminel la
maison va être confisquée et placée sous
scellé en attendant que le Service des
Antiquités explore le puits
ces petits pilleurs qui rêvent de
fortune sont souvent les seuls à payer
les réseaux organisés de trafiquants eux
restent largement impuni
en Égypte les antiquités ne sont jamais
vraiment à l'abri même les musées
peuvent être la cible des pilleurs
la célèbre place tarir au centre du
Caire c'est ici que la Révolution a
éclaté et elle a failli faire
disparaître ce que le pays a de plus
précieux le Musée des Antiquités
égyptiennes
dans ce bâtiment construit en 1902 par
un architecte français sont exposés les
plus beaux joyaux de l’égypte ancienne à
commencer par le trésor de Toutankhamon
[Musique]
en janvier 2011 le musée du Caire se
retrouve au cœur de la révolte
la nuit tombe sur la place tarir la
situation est en train d'échapper à tout
contrôle
lorsqu'on dirait à la télévision un
homme va lancer un cri d'alarme
[Applaudissements]
du musée et maintenant il a peur que ce
groupe parvienne à s'introduire dans le
musée pour le pilier qu'est-ce que vous
avez vu exactement
je m'adresse à l'armée pour qu'elle
vienne immédiatement au Musée égyptien
pour le protéger
Khaled Youssef est un réalisateur de
cinéma connu dans tout le pays des
milliers d'Égyptiens vont entendre son
appel
je demande aux gens de ne pas respecter
le couvre-feu et d'occuper le terrain
jusqu'à ce que l'armée arrive
que notre sang si notre musée est
attaqué
comme les pillages qui ont eu lieu en
Irak pendant la guerre
[Musique]
immédiatement une chaîne humaine
s'organise autour du musée
pendant 14 jours des milliers de
volontaires vont se relayer pour monter
la garde vous êtes là pour protéger le
musée
et vous avez passé toute la journée ici
et la nuit dernière aussi
[Applaudissements]
quatre ans après la Révolution Khaled
Youssef n'oublie pas cette nuit qui a
fait de lui un héros
une notoriété qui lui vaut d’être
régulièrement arrêté par des admirateurs
[Musique]
c'est ici que j'ai vécu le moment le
plus important de ma vie la plupart des
gens qui m'interpellent aujourd'hui ne
me connaissaient pas avant et ils me
disent on t'a vu à la télé pendant la
Révolution c'est toi qui pleurait en
disant sauver le musée du Caire
voilà les merveilles que Khaled Youssef
a contribué à protéger
160000 objets découverts dans toutes les
gîtes
des statues
du mobilier funéraire finement sculpté
et recouvert d'orphins
des momies ou encore des bijoux royaux à
la valeur inestimable
[Musique]
tous ces trésors sont exposés dans des
salles vétustes où les conditions de
sécurité n'ont pas beaucoup changé
depuis l'ouverture du musée il y a plus
d'un siècle
les vitrines sont en bois
et le vert n'est même pas blindé
j'étais là au moment de la Révolution je
vous ai vu à la télé voici le chef des
gardiens du musée
[Musique]
lorsque Khaled Youssef a lancé son appel
lui et son équipe était en train de se
faire déborder par les pillards dans la
boutique du musée
comme le montre ses images de
vidéosurveillance
le chef de la sécurité n'a pas pu
empêcher d'autres voleurs d'accéder aux
salles d'exposition en passant par les
toits ils sont entrés par là
ils ont réussi à sauter non ils se sont
servis de câble téléphonique ils sont
tombés ici sur la vitrine elle a cassé
et du coup il y en a un qui s'est blessé
vous voyez la trace de sang ici
les voleurs fractures plusieurs vitrines
et emporte 52 pièces de grandes valeurs
comme ces statues de bois dorés que la
police finira par retrouver briser en
plusieurs morceaux
certaines ont pu être complètement
restauré
[Musique]
quelques mètres plus loin les pillards
atteignent l'entrée de la salle qui
abrite le trésor le plus célèbre
d'Égypte celui du pharaon Toutankhamon
là il y a de l'or
pas de porte blindée ni de détecteur de
mouvement
à la fermeture du musée en fin de
journée on ferme les deux portes
et on verrouille avec la chaîne
le jour du pillage cette simple chaîne a
pourtant suffit à sauver le célèbre
masque funéraire de Toutankhamon 11
kilos d'or pur et de pierres
semi-précieuses
dans la salle également de sarcophages
doré qui protégeait la momie du
souverain
[Musique]
ainsi que de nombreux bijoux trouvé sur
la dépouille de Toutankhamon
le seul pharaon de l'histoire dont la
sépulture soit restée inviolée jusqu'à
sa découverte en 1922
[Musique]
imaginez ce que penserait le monde si le
masque de Toutankhamon une pièce vieille
de plus de 3000 ans disparaissait
comment on se serait justifié vis-à-vis
de l'humanité de ne pas avoir su
protéger une antiquité aussi importante
la police a finalement arrêté plus d'une
dizaine de pilleurs et retrouvez plus de
la moitié des pièces volées au musée ce
jour-là
pour mettre son patrimoine archéologique
à l'abri l'Egypte a lancé un gigantesque
projet chaque semaine un convoi quitte
le musée du Caire sous haute
surveillance
dans cette caisse des antiquités
pharaoniques qui vont discrètement
traverser la ville
escorté par une dizaine de policiers
dans des voitures banalisées
[Musique]
direction le nouveau grand musée
égyptien actuellement en construction
dans la banlieue du Caire un chantier de
près d'un milliard d'euros pour ce qui
doit être le plus vaste musée
d'antiquités du monde 600 mètres de
longueur au pied des pyramides de Gizeh
[Musique]
cette construction de béton aux allures
de forteresse ce sont les zones de
stockage du musée
[Musique]
ces entrepôts sont ultra sécurisés la
présence d'une caméra y est
exceptionnelle
c'est le directeur du musée lui-même qui
a suivi la conception et l'avancée des
travaux
et contre les intrusions c'est un bon
cœur conçu pour accueillir le patrimoine
de l'humanité que l'Égypte a le devoir
de protéger
c'est également ici que se trouvent les
laboratoires de restauration
d'antiquités les plus modernes du pays
la qualité de l'air ambiant y est
contrôlé en permanence pour ne pas
détériorer les objets qui s'y trouvent
voici la délit du pharaon Toutankhamon
il est fait de bois et recouvert d'or
comme chaque pièce qui arrive ici Soline
nécessitera des dizaines d'heures de
restauration avant de pouvoir être
exposés
[Musique]
nous travaillons sur des matières
organiques le bois ou les fibres
naturelles qui ont près de 3500 ans
cela veut dire qu'ils sont parfois dans
un état critique et notre personnel a
pour mission de prolonger leur vie et de
les préparer pour une exposition future
se lit sur lequel le pharaon a peut-être
dormi n'a encore jamais été montré au
public
et le grand musée promet de plonger le
visiteur dans l'intimité de Toutankhamon
avec cette collection de linge et de
sous-vêtements en lin lui ayant
appartenu tout a été retrouvé intact
dans sa tombe
pour la première fois l'intégralité des
objets qui ont été trouvés dans la tombe
de Toutankhamon sera exposée
jusqu'à présent le public ne connaissait
qu'un tiers environ de ce qui a été
découvert maintenant l'ensemble des 4500
objets de la tombe sera exposé ici
c'est dans cette salle la plus sécurisée
de tout le musée que ces milliers
d'objets jamais montrés au public sont
entreposés ils apportent un éclairage
inédit sur le quotidien de Toutankhamon
il y a plus de 3000 ans mobilier
barque funéraire miniature
boîte à provisions
[Musique]
et même différentes sortes de fruits et
de graines dans un état de conservation
étonnant
il y a aussi ces boomangs de chasse
incrustés au nom du pharaon
ou encore les sandales de Toutankhamon
des techniques et la technique de
fabrication de ses sandales comme ce
sont des objets royaux et très soignés
leurs degré de perfection surpasse celui
de n'importe quel sandale fabriqué
aujourd'hui avec des machines
industrielles
les découvertes les plus émouvantes du
trésor de Toutankhamon sont pour
l'instant conservés dans ces deux boîtes
en carton
et voici un triste épisode de l'histoire
de Toutankhamon ces deux fœtuses de
petites filles mortes avantaires qui ont
été enterrés avec lui dans sa tombe
deux petites momies qui sont sans doute
les filles du pharaon
pour la première fois elles seront
exposées dans notre grand musée égyptien
comme partie intégrante du Trésor
complet de Toutankhamon
mais le chantier du plus grand musée
archéologique du monde a pris du retard
et l'inauguration n'est pas prévue avant
2018 les touristes ne sont pas près de
le visiter alors en attendant
sera battent sur un grand classique
à 600 km au sud du Caire entre Louxor et
à soi voici le circuit incontournable
pour ceux qui veulent explorer l'Egypte
des pharaons
la croisière sur le Nil
5 jours de navigation à la découverte
des principaux monuments de la Haute
Égypte
des paysages à couper le souffle
mais aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup moins
de monde pour en profiter
avant la révolution de 2011 600 000
Français visité le pays chaque année
aujourd'hui ils sont quatre fois moins
nombreux
parmi eux il y a Catherine et Xavier
elle est professeur de lycée il est
agent de maîtrise chez EDF et tous deux
ont voulu faire découvrir l'Egypte alors
deux enfants Marianne et Antoine
je pense hein l'Égypte ça fait rêver
dans les livres d'histoire on a qu'une
seule envie c'est s'y rendre et on s'est
dit bah c'est l'occasion jamais
première journée de croisière est déjà
un avant-goût du folklore local de
chaque côté du bateau des vendeurs de
tissus se sont accrochés et tentent
d'attirer l'attention des touristes
c'est un abordable
fluvial je préfère essayer sur place
tranquillement
pourtant quelques instants plus tard
Xavier se laisse tenter par cet ensemble
traditionnel
[Applaudissements]
15 euros de ristourne mais Xavier n'est
toujours pas convaincu le vendeur se
rabat sur d'autres civils
[Applaudissements]
et voilà comment les clients peuvent
voir la marchandise de près
[Applaudissements]
le tourisme en moi il revient
mon sac l'argent de la vente va faire le
chemin en sens inverse
mais pour les vendeurs du Nil les
affaires n'ont jamais été aussi
mauvaises qu'aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
car le Semiramis II qui transporte la
famille de Catherine et Xavier est
toujours dit l'un des seuls hôtels
flottants qui continuent de naviguer sur
le Nil
[Musique]
et le bateau est loin d'être plein
d'ordinaire il peut accueillir jusqu'à
140 passagers mais cette semaine il n'y
a que 80 touristes dont une moitié de
français
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Catherine Xavier et leurs deux enfants
ont donc pu choisir leur cabine
elles sont situées juste l'une en face
de l'autre
[Musique]
cabine ici c'est la cabine des garçons
donc mon fils et moi vous avez fait bien
son fils voilà on a fait garçon fille ça
permet
entre mon fils et moi te retrouver un
petit peu entre garçons voilà alors lui
il regarde la télé derrière et moi je
suis une télé c'est celle-ci et ça je
m'en lasse pas
voilà une fenêtre avec vue sur le Nil
an
et de grandes cabines récemment refaites
inconfort comparable à celui d'un trois
étoiles
mais ce qui a surtout séduit la famille
de Xavier c'est le prix cassé du séjour
on appelle 640 euros par personne tout
compris
la restauration
matin midi et soir bien sûr soit au
total 2500 euros la croisière d'une
semaine pour quatre personnes vol
compris
avec un petit coeur
des tarifs imbattables
mais les tours opérateurs n'ont pas le
choix car en ce moment l'Egypte est une
destination qui inquiète les passagers
du Sémiramis ont souvent dû vaincre les
réticences de leur entourage avant de
partir
c'est le cas de Stéphanie une mère de
famille venue seule avec ses deux
enfants Louise 15 ans et Paul 11 ans
on m'a dit que c'était vraiment une
folie de partir en Égypte la petite
blague était de toutes les façons tu as
pas payé trop cher puisque tu auras pas
le retour voilà donc c'est le genre de
blague qu'on vous dit lorsque vous dites
partir en Egypte donc du coup c'est vrai
que j'ai passé pas mal de temps sur le
site du ministère des Affaires
étrangères et là effectivement tout est
fait pour vous empêcher d'y aller c'est
très anxiogène en fait ce qui est écrit
un contexte sécuritaire tendu qui sur le
Sémiramis se traduit par la présence
d'un policier armé dans le poste de
pilotage loin des yeux des touristes
mais pour Stéphanie la méfiance
qu'inspire l'Égypte en ce moment à
paradoxalement était un argument dans
son choix de venir ici
on est tout seul donc vous bénéficiez
d'un prix hyper attractif aux enfants
sont super heureux il y a plein d'autres
enfants sur le bateau donc c'est
ambiance vraiment vacances et en plus on
bénéficie d'une histoire
ultra riche
sur le navire les passagers ne sont pas
seulement venus ici pour faire du
farnien le programme du groupe est
plutôt chargé au moins une escale par
jour pour visiter des sites
archéologiques
la destination d'aujourd'hui le temple
de filae l'un des joyaux du Nil on prend
le bateau là c'est ça
sur une île à une dizaine de kilomètres
au sud d'Assouan
pour s'y rendre il faut prendre un petit
bateau
sur lequel des vendeurs de souvenirs
sont en embuscade
faut que je
réfléchisseurs nos touristes n'ont pas
vraiment le temps de profiter de la vue
le temple de filae est l'un des mieux
conservés d'Egypte
son style est typique de la toute
dernière dynastie qui régna sur le pays
celle de la reine Cléopâtre
Stéphanie et ses enfants ont un peu de
mal à prendre congé des vendeurs
ah bon il a dit que c'était du plastique
ok ok
after
de la traversée c'est une toute autre
atmosphère qui attend les visiteurs à
l'intérieur du site
ah c'est extraordinaire franchement
incroyable parce que souvent ce qu'on
reproche au visite c'est d'être les uns
sur les autres
Stéphanie était déjà venu ici il y a 20
ans le calme qui règne aujourd'hui n'a
rien à voir avec ce qu'elle a connu à
l'époque on arrive à l'entrée on avait
des dizaines de quarts il y avait des
dizaines de bateaux voilà c'était un peu
comme Versailles ou des lieux comme ça
très très couru par les touristes
le temple a été construit en l'honneur
d'Isis la principale déesse de
l'ancienne Égypte à l'intérieur il est
presque intact pour Catherine Xavier et
leurs enfants impossible de résister au
charme du lieu
on a l'impression d'être seul au
monde on a l'impression
qu'on quasiment des pharaons quoi donc
ça c'est super chouette
un voyage dans le temps dans des
conditions privilégiées qui va se
conclure par une petite prière à Isis au
coeur de son sanctuaire
pour conjurer le mauvais œil
la grande magicienne
nous sommes venus
vous adorez vous adorez
à ne plus aller plus poser des questions
à notre guide
[Rires]
fin de la journée
et retour sur le Sémiramis
ou après le repas du soir au
self-service les touristes vont avoir
droit à un grand classique des
croisières sur le Nil la soirée djellaba
une soirée à laquelle les passagers sont
invités à participer en se déguisant
c'est aussi l'occasion pour la boutique
du bateau de faire de bonnes affaires
en proposant ces costumes typiques
Paul et Louise les enfants de Stéphanie
sont venus faire leur choix
de plus
la coiffe traditionnelle du désert
dans la salle de balle du navire la fête
bat son plein
musique traditionnelle
et dervichtner
une ambiance à laquelle Paul dans son
nouveau costume ne va pas résister bien
longtemps
[Applaudissements]
il est accro à la danse il adore et très
beau
naturel chez lui
la soirée ne va pas s'éterniser car
demain nos touristes vont poursuivre
leur périple le long du Nil et leur
programme est très chargé
ce tourisme de masse qui faisait vivre
toute la Haute Égypte et devenue
totalement sinistrée
avant 2011 300 navires identiques au
Sémiramis naviguaient sur le Nil en
permanence aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus
qu'une trentaine un effondrement aux
conséquences dramatique le long du
fleuve des dizaines de bateaux autrefois
prix d'assaut par les touristes sont
hackés depuis 5 ans cela appartiennent à
une compagnie égyptienne qui travaillait
avec des tours opérateurs français
allemands et britanniques
avant la Révolution Agag le responsable
de la compagnie à Louxor accueillait
jusqu'à 800 touristes par semaine sur
ces sept bateaux il est toujours nuit
condamné à les regarder rouillée
nous sommes sur un bateau qui s'appelle
DaVinci
compte 65 cabines
ce navire est à quai depuis la
Révolution
le temps s'est figé il y a 4 ans
au mur les clichés d'une soirée djellaba
des Britanniques photographiés début
2011 il était alors impossible
d'imaginer que seulement quelques
semaines plus tard tout allait s'arrêter
ce sont les photos du dernier groupe qui
a voyagé à bord de ce bateau
avant il y avait des groupes qui
partaient qui arrivaient un équipage qui
travaillait il y avait une vie et
aujourd'hui c'est sinistre comme une
caverne
[Musique]
dans les cabines rien n'a bougé ou
presque comme si les prochains touristes
étaient sur le point d'embarquer
les cabines sont encore fonctionnelles
mais avant il faudrait faire le ménage
ça fait longtemps que ça n'a pas été
fait il y a de la poussière partout
si les chambres sont encore en état 5
années d'abandon ont déjà causé au
DaVinci des dégâts considérables
pour s'en rendre compte il faut monter
sur le pont supérieur
il y a de la poussière et des toiles
d'araignées partout
regardez dans quel état sont les tables
et les chaises
elle dessine la piscine est dans un état
catastrophique c'est un cauchemar
pour remettre ses bateaux dans l'état
dans lesquels ils étaient avant la
Révolution il faudrait des centaines de
milliers d'euros pour repartir
pas question d'investir dans une
rénovation alors qu'il n'y a plus de
touristes et la compagnie continue de
perdre de l'argent tous les jours car il
faut payer les salaires d'une quinzaine
de marins qui ne sont là que pour faire
du gardiennage
elle marque le bateau est abandonné mais
il y a des marins qui restent ici pour
le garder et l'entretenir
je vais vous montrer l'endroit où ils
vivent bonjour
les bateaux risqueraient d'être
dépouillés
aujourd'hui
90% des bateaux de croisière du Nil sont
hackés faute de clients et les touristes
ne semblent pas décider à revenir en
masse
retour près du Caire au pied des
pyramides du désert de Saqqara
l'archéologue français facile de bref
attaque une nouvelle phase de sa
campagne de fouilles
[Musique]
depuis 15 ans Vasile se concentre sur
une petite surface un chantier de 50
mètres de côté qui l'explorent
méthodiquement et s'il s'est installé
ici ça n'est pas par hasard
la chaise c'est le Père Lachaise
comme à Paris bien faire de la chaise
sur 3000 ans
ce cimetière est un vrai filon pour les
archéologues
va-t-il vient justement de découvrir une
tombe impressionnante la plus vaste
jamais trouvée ici
cette structure de 12 mètres de côté ce
sont les fondations d'un mastaba un
grand tombeau de briques qui abritait
une multitude de pluie funéraires
chacun d'entre eux peut potentiellement
mener un caveau souterrain et à de
nouveaux trésors
[Musique]
mais en surface l'archéologue a aussi
découvert plusieurs squelettes qui ont
été enterrés sur le mastaba plus de 1000
ans après sa construction
on a un squelette ici mais il peut très
bien être placé sur un autre squelette
un jour je m'appelle j'ai trouvé 5
squelettes les uns en tout cas les
autres
l'étude des squelettes c'est l'affaire
de Diane l'anthropologue du chantier
aujourd'hui exceptionnellement elle est
venue travailler avec son fils Victor
deux ans et demi et déjà une vocation
d'archéologues
et ce que vous trouviez
je lui ai donné les mots qui sait que ce
sont des ossements des autres et ça
s'appelle un squelette
je parle pour l'instant et c'est pas que
c'est ce qu'il a sous la peau c'est ça
qu'on trouve après vu qu'il est encore
peut-être un peu petit pour qu'on s'est
actualiser le fait que une fois que on
est mort voilà il reste ça après et
voici l'homme qui est chargé de faire
les relevés de la mission
il s'appelle Olivier et c'est le père de
Victor il est au grand air il est dehors
la plupart des enfants à cet âge là sont
sont en crèches toute la journée bon ben
lui il est avec ses parents dehors dans
le désert sur un chantier archéologique
c'est pas tous les enfants qui peuvent
participer à ce genre de d'aventure
un peu plus loin les ouvriers ont appelé
Vasil car leurs outils viennent de buter
contre un gros bloc de calcaire qui n'a
rien à faire là
[Applaudissements]
c'est le couvercle d'un sarcophage en
pierre il est encore scellé il a
confirmé va parce qu'on a l'induit oui
là c'est le couvercle ici là c'est
l'enduit qu'il sait et en bas ça va être
la cuve un sarcophage encore scellé sur
le chantier l'excitation monte d'un cran
car à l'intérieur se trouve peut-être
encore une momie
l'ouverture d'un sarcophage c'est donc
toujours un moment fort pour un
archéologue allez maintenant on va
l'ouvrir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non c'est pas une vraie
c'est juste enveloppé
[Applaudissements]
18 ans comment vous savez ça quand les
3e molaires là sont pas encore sortis ça
plus les épices qui sont pas soudés sur
les sur les eaux tout ça ça nous montre
que c'est c'est encore un jeune
adolescent à la différence d'une momie
le corps n'a pas été embaumé pour le
préserver mais simplement enveloppé de
bandelettes c'est déjà le signe d'un
enterrement particulièrement soigné
pour étudier le squelette et tenter de
comprendre les causes de la mort Diane
va les retirer
plusieurs épaisseurs
il y a vraiment
grande quantité de bandelettes qui sont
enroulées autour du corps pas d'objet
dans cette sépulture mais pour voici
chaque découverte lui en apprend un peu
plus sur la façon dont les Égyptiens
envisageaient la mort
les choses très importantes un Egypte
ancienne on disait pas il est mort ils
vont dire son souffle et ses envolé
il est sorti du corps
pour que le souffle puisse retourner
dans le corps donc pour le préserver le
momifier
cette obsession de la vie après la mort
était celle de toute la société
égyptienne a commencé par le pharaon qui
disposait d'une tombe hors du commun la
pyramide voisine qui appartient au roi
Joseph a presque 5000 ans c'est le plus
ancien monument de pierre de l'histoire
de l'humanité
sa restauration abrute allemand était
interrompue à la Révolution il y a 5 ans
aujourd'hui exceptionnellement voici les
Diane ont été autorisés à monter
jusqu'au sommet grâce à cet échafaudage
laissé en place à l'arrêt des travaux
[Musique]
on peut admirer toute l'histoire de
l'ancienne empire Lisa c'est magnifique
au nord le plateau de Gizeh et les
célèbres pyramides de Khéops qui freine
et Micky rinos au sud les deux pyramides
du pharaon néfro le père de Khéops et
tout autour une multitude d'autres
édifices plus ou moins bien conservés
c'est vraiment magnifique c'est la
première fois que je monte en haut d'une
pyramide
c'est un bon début
ici ça a commencé on est monté des 10
mètres 60 mètres là on était à 105
mètres mais quand même deux grandes
pyramides et là-bas 147 c'est un peu
comme une compétition entre eux c'est à
dire l'idée était de rejoindre quand
même le soleil plus haut tu es plus haut
plus près du soleil et là quand même
c'est beaucoup plus frais du soleil
qu'en bas
aujourd'hui on dénombre environ 120
pyramides en Égypte un magnifique
terrain de jeu pour les archéologues
[Musique]
fin de la journée de travail c'est dans
la voiture de Vasil que toute la famille
rentre au coeur
[Musique]
Diane et Olivier sont arrivés en Égypte
fin 2010 juste avant la Révolution
malgré les troubles ils ont choisi de
rester pour vivre pleinement leur
passion de l'Égypte ancienne
[Musique]
allez à demain bonne soirée
aujourd'hui ils sont installés dans un
quartier résidentiel au sud du Caire un
appartement confortable de 200 mètres
carrés loin de la frénésie du
centre-ville Le Caire compte aujourd'hui
plus de 16 millions d'habitants une
mégalopole impressionnante dans laquelle
Victor se sent pourtant comme un poisson
dans l'eau
ce matin quand même
dans une petite clinique
il est chez lui
mais ici dans le quartier pour l'instant
j'ai jamais eu de problème dans la rue
en marchant avec lui au contrat des gens
en général sont très gentils surtout dès
qu'il y a un petit
bonjour il faut dire que Victor commence
à être connu dans le quartier alors
Victor qu'est-ce qu'on achète
les commerçants se sont attachés à ce
petit français qu'il voit régulièrement
ils font tout pour lui faire plaisir
tu en veux pas tu veux pas
aller excellence
si Diane est à l'aise dans son quartier
elle hésite cependant à s'éloigner de
son appartement depuis la Révolution
il y a des endroits où on n'ira pas ça
c'est sûr il y a des endroits où on
allait avant et où on ira plus en tout
cas pour l'instant
le charislamique tout le quartier du
charislamique peut-être que ça craint
rien du tout c'est possible mais
effectivement bon on préfère ne pas y
aller le centre-ville la place tarir
tout ça on n'est jamais à l'abri de
tomber sur une manifestation même si
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui elles sont un
peu plus réglementées mais enfin bon il
y a eu quand même pas mal de problèmes
autour de la place d'arrêt en tout cas
pour victoire pour moi dans le quartier
ça va
malgré la situation parfois instable en
Égypte Diane ne prévoit pas de rentrer
en France pour le moment
le lendemain au pied de ce qui est sans
doute la plus mystérieuse des pyramides
d'Égypte le tombeau de Snefrou le père
de Khéops 105 mètres de haut strictement
fermé au public il est très rare de
pouvoir y pénétrer même pour un
egyptologue Vassil n'a pu l'explorer que
quatre fois depuis le début de sa
carrière pour lui toutes les autres
pyramides n'ont fait que copier les
principes qui ont été inventés ici il y
a 4700 ans
ça c'est le couloir qui descend vers la
les entrailles de la pyramide vers la
première chambre et là on a 70 mètres et
on doit se pencher une robe parce que
c'est à peine à mettre sur un mètre
pratiquement et
donc quelque part quand on rentre vers
le toboggan on doit se plier
on va utiliser l'encoche
pour accéder au cœur de la pyramide il
faut franchir de nombreux obstacles
voici le progresse par une série de
galeries de plus en plus étroites
tout droit une architecture complexe
dont personne n'a jamais vraiment
compris la logique à quoi ça sert je
sais pas
ça venduro et ça descend je sais pas où
il est encore peut-être une autre
chambre trouver
après une demi-heure d'exploration
va-t-il parvient enfin dans ce qui fut
autrefois la chambre funéraire du
pharaon une chambre mystère car
contrairement aux autres pyramides
d'Égypte elle était à sa découverte
totalement vide
on n'a jamais trouvé ça
les pyramides fonctionnaient comme des
machines à résurrection le roi
renaissait dans son tombeau puis montait
vers le ciel par ce long couloir
toujours dirigé vers le nord
c'est sans doute par là dans l'Antiquité
que les pilleurs se sont glissés pour
s'emparer des objets de valeur du
pharaon cette règle pour les permis et
aussi leur faiblesse parce que les
voleurs par la suite se fait
parfaitement que pour un 13e pyramide il
faut aller au centre de la face au
milieu de la face nord et chercher le
coureur qui descend dans la pyramide
c'est pour ça que les droits suivants
ont changé ils ont commencé à mettre des
faux couloirs des couloirs à l'est de
couleur au sud du couloir à l'ouest pour
tromper les voleurs
malgré leur ingéniosité les Pharaons ont
rarement réussi à mettre leur trésor à
l'abri des voleurs
Toutankhamon et le soleil être parvenu
sur le Nil la nuit a été très courte
pour les passagers du Sémiramis
Stéphanie et ses enfants se sont levés
aux aurores pour aller voir un temple
édifié par le célèbre Ramsès II quelle
heure il est là il est 3h45 je pense
2h30
on part à
visiter le temple à 250 km au sud en
fait en cas
pour ce qu'il faut y être en fait pour
le lever du soleil
cinq minutes pour prendre un café en
fait
oreiller sous le bras pour dormir dans
le bus une quarantaine de courageux ont
payé 90 euros par personne pour aller
visiter le célèbre temple d'Abou Simbel
bon chers amis le bonjour à tous le
bonjour à toutes et est-ce que ça va
tout le monde c'est dur un peu mais vous
n'allez pas regretter ce matin on va on
va admirer le plus beau temple considéré
comme le plus de temps que vous allez
admirer cette semaine
pour visiter à boussimbel les touristes
venus de plusieurs bateaux doivent
voyager en convoi d'une vingtaine de bus
qui vont partir d'Assouan et rouler en
plein désert durant 4 heures jusqu'à la
frontière soudanaise à l'extrême sud du
pays
dans le groupe nous retrouvons Catherine
Xavier et leurs enfants un peu étonné
par le déploiement de force matinale 40
policiers seront affectés à la sécurité
du convoi pour prévenir tout risque
d'attentat
rendre ou visiblement il faut un certain
nombre de forces de sécurité et le guide
nous disait même que durant le trajet il
fallait il était interdit de que le bus
s'arrête ça fait partie de la sécurité
donc c'est bon c'est vrai qu'on a tout
un convoi si c'est le prix à payer pour
ça on y va quoi à l'insu des touristes
chaque bus est protégé par un policier
en civil armé d'un pistolet mitrailleur
après 4 heures de route dans le désert
le soleil est déjà levé depuis longtemps
quand le convoi atteint les premiers
contrôles de sécurité du site d'Abou
Simbel
la visite va s'effectuer au pas de
course 1h30 passe une minute de plus un
peu court pour apprécier la splendeur de
ce temple au bord du lac Nasser
célèbre pour ses colosses de pierre à
l'effigie du pharaon Ramsès II
ah ils sont bien cachés
c'est super
il y a encore 50 ans ce lac n'existait
pas et le temple était situé 65 mètres
plus bas
condamné à être submergé par la
construction d'un grand barrage
électrique sur le Nil le temple et ses
colosses ont été démontés dans les
années 60 l'opération de sauvetage
archéologique la plus spectaculaire de
tous les temps
à la scie les ouvriers ont découpé plus
d'un millier de morceaux qui ont été
soigneusement numérotés
les statues ont ensuite été remontées
bloc par bloc sur une colline
artificielle
un chantier titanesque supervisé par
l'UNESCO est dirigée par des
archéologues français
imaginez avec moi que le temple était
dans l'eau ils vont isolé il y avait des
blocs qui faisaient entre 8 tonnes et 14
tonnes
même si on se lève aux aurores alors là
il y a
la fatigue est complètement estompée en
dormira au retour dans le car
Ramsès II fit édifié ce temple à sa
propre gloire alors on commence par où
là tout y est disproportionné
ces statues monumentales ça écrase quoi
ça nous écrase complètement on est
vraiment au pied de Ramsès il y a pas à
dire voilà c'est ça
[Musique]
omniprésent que l'on voit partout sur
les murs Ramsès
il est représenté en train de terrasser
ses ennemis
Ramsès II a régné pendant 66 ans jusqu'à
sa mort 1200 ans avant Jésus-Christ
jamais plus l'Egypte ne sera aussi
puissante qu'à son époque
pour nos touristes ce voyage est une
révélation qui leur fait prendre
conscience de l'ampleur et du
raffinement atteint par la civilisation
égyptienne
[Musique]
on est d'accord
mais au programme de la croisière il n'y
a pas seulement des escales culturels
pour varier les plaisirs aujourd'hui les
touristes sont conviés à la visite d'une
fabrique de papyrus
sauf que l'endroit ressemble davantage à
une boutique de souvenirs pour donner le
change à l'entrée il y a un employé qui
fait une démonstration express
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est impressionnant c'est dur sur la
presse
[Applaudissements]
après deux minutes d'explication le
vendeur rentre dans le vif du sujet
car s'il y a bien une chose qui n'a pas
changé en Égypte c'est la tradition
d'acheter du papyrus décoré ici il y en
a pour tous les goûts et toutes les
religions et ça marche les touristes
sont toujours intéressés
Antoine un petit comment dirais-je un
petit papyrus avec une illustration qui
lui plaise et on ajouterait son prénom
comme ça ça lui permettra de voir son
prénom symbole égyptien quant à
Stéphanie elle a envie d'offrir un
cadeau à ses enfants
[Applaudissements]
et les prix affichés en livres
égyptienne difficile de faire le bon
choix
[Applaudissements]
non c'est pas facile mais j'ai je
préfère les foncer ça je trouve ça
magnifique faut que je vois faut que je
calcule un peu
celui-là
oui oui c'est celui-ci voilà
en plus ça c'est dans les couleurs de ta
chambre donc c'est sympa
en quelques minutes le prénom d'Antoine
est dessiné sur le papier russe et
l'encre séché en express
tout est fait pour pousser un peu à la
consommation
du côté de Stéphanie la tentation de
s'offrir un papyrus et de plus en plus
forte
[Applaudissements]
mal avec le taux de change
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok donc ça fait combien là pour
l'addition le vendeur préfère entraîner
Stéphanie jusqu'à la caisse
on va savoir
2030 blue 40 2070 comme voyage merci
[Applaudissements]
en France 258 euros pour trois papyrus
ça y est les amis on y va s'il vous
plaît une bonne journée pour le guide
qui a dû prendre sa commission au
passage en Égypte il y a des traditions
qui ne se perdent pas
et c'est tant mieux car certaines ne
manquent pas de charme comme la visite
du temple de Louxor à la tombée de la
nuit
[Musique]
ou encore la promenade à dos de
dromadaire le long du Nil
es
[Rires]
comme autant des caravanes dans le
désert
c'est super beau
un voyage inoubliable pour ses familles
françaises
la suite de la promenade risque d'être
un peu moins authentique
leur guide les entraînent dans un
village typique qui ressemble davantage
à un attrape touriste
malgré les tentations stéphanie est bien
décidé cette fois-ci à ne pas se faire
avoir
mais devant les étals débordant des
pistes colorés difficile de garder la
tête froide
non c'est tout
et là on sait pas le prix à chaque fois
livres soit 9 euros pour un petit sachet
d'épices vendu en vrac
stéphanie a comme un doute
on comprend pas en fait ce qui donne un
prix au gramme et puis finalement
apparemment c'est pas au gramme mais ce
serait plutôt au grammes donc
apparemment je me faisais arnaquer je
payais 10 fois le prix donc du coup j'ai
laissé le paquet ce qui est très mal
élevé merci donc voilà parce que quand
il fait chaud non non mais c'est bon
c'est bon
[Musique]
en une semaine de croisière nos
touristes français ont autant appris sur
l'Égypte antique que sur le commerce à
l'Oriental
[Musique]
sur le plateau de Saqqara facile à
sortir les grands moyens pour faire
avancer son chantier de fouille
cette grue va permettre de tripler la
cadence l'archéologue est pressé de
vider ce puits aux dimensions
exceptionnelles le plus prometteur du
tombeau qu'il vient de découvrir
à Sakara où les méthodes de fouilles
sont entièrement manuels l'arrivée d'une
grue est un événement
et les ouvriers sont plus motivés que
jamais
à ce rythme là le fond est vite atteint
après de 15 mètres sous la surface
plus question d'échelle pour descendre
aussi
bascule n'a pas le choix il doit
embarquer dans cette petite nacelle et
il n'est pas très rassuré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au fond les ouvriers se sont arrêtés à
l'entrée d'une chambre funéraire
et les premiers coups de pinceau sont
prometteurs car elle a l'air intacte
c'est ici c'est le début du creusement
pour la chambre la voûte de la montagne
et elle était entièrement scellée on va
bien
l'enduit noir la boue noire qui a été
utilisé pour fermer
la chambre qui est derrière
et là ça nous montre que personne est
rentré à l'intérieur depuis les portes
de fermeture de cette pièce
ça c'est exceptionnel ah oui ça
peut-être arrivé une forme dans une vie
ce que facile espèce c'est que la tombe
soit fermée depuis l'enterrement il y a
plus de 4000 ans
à l'intérieur pourrait donc se trouver
le sarcophage et des objets précieux qui
accompagnaient le défunt dans l'au-delà
[Musique]
mais sur la partie gauche le scellement
de la tombe semble avoir été entamée
un petit trou un trou et les briques
sont pas en place
je me pose la question est-ce que
quelqu'un n'est pas descendu d'un
antiquité comme ça d'ici en laissant ça
de côté
facile pense qu'un pilleur a pu se
glisser par cette petite ouverture mais
aurait-il tout emporté
pour en avoir le cœur net il faut
dégager l'ouverture et dans les gravats
première surprise
ça devient intéressant
un vase miniature en albâtre voilà c'est
comme ça à l'intérieur
oh là là c'est la qualité de travail tu
as quand même magnifique là c'est très
très juste très fin très bien fait ça
montre que certains qualités et
l'importance du personnage qui est
dedans on vous forme ça on sait pas
encore mais c'est un bon signe c'est
impossible
la valeur marchande de ce petit vase
dépasse la dizaine de milliers d'euros à
partir de cet instant avec des objets
d'aussi petites tailles et d'aussi
grandes valeurs il faut avancer
prudemment
le sable retiré du puits est tamisé pour
ne rien laisser passer
l'équipe parvient enfin au niveau de la
chambre funéraire
la chambre commence ici avec
l'inscription
donc la chambre est entièrement décorée
et remplie de sable
c'est bien mieux que l'autre
et ben voilà encore une autre découverte
c'est bien meilleur travail j'arrive pas
à voir son nom c'est un peu loin
c'est beaucoup plus joli
c'est beaucoup plus joli et c'est
évident
sur le seuil de la tombe une nouvelle
trouvaille un objet très précieux
c'est une petite tablette oui c'est la
tablette qu'on attend vous voyez les
petits les petits pots qu'on a vu les
petits pots peut-être elle était posée
dessus la tablette est gravée et elle
donne le nom du défunt
oui donc c'est
très intéressant en haut il y a une
petite ligne qui lit de droite à gauche
qui nous donne le propriétaire
Marty en puissant de vie
peut-être pour les huiles
malheureusement les vidages je reviens
s'il y avait encore quelques gouttes
d'huile pour mettre sous la main pour
sentir bon
[Applaudissements]
à l'intérieur de la tombe facile et
Abdou découvre des céramiques elle
devait contenir de la bière de l'huile
et des céréales pour que le défunt
puisse s'alimenter après sa résurrection
[Musique]
tout ça est en place depuis l'Antiquité
on a le bouchon en plâtre voilà on va
bien
la jarre bah c'est exactement celle
qu'on voit ici il y a un bouchon ici bon
qu'on va pas sur le dessin on dirait que
c'est cette forme là à peu près monsieur
là c'est un peu plus allongé mais c'est
les gens peut-être à lui là
mélangez au sable Vasile trouve aussi de
minuscules objets auxquels la plupart
d'entre nous n'accorderaient aucune
importance
celui-ci a pourtant à pouvoir magique
c'est ce qu'on appelle le couteau de
l'ouverture de la bouche l'instrument
qui peut permettre d'ouvrir la bouche au
dessin celui qui est mort pour que le
souffle de la vie retourne son souffle
rentre dans la momie pour qu'il puisse
revivre
une nouvelle surprise
une feuille d'or
très très mince un travail
magnifique
investige des bijoux sans doute déposés
auprès du défunt au moment de
l'enterrement comme ce collier
représenté sur les murs de la tombe ça
c'est quand même bien la preuve dans
l'atome il y avait des objets dorés
d'une grande vol
la mission de Vassil est financée par la
France mais toutes ces découvertes
appartiennent à l’égypte et resteront
dans le pays certaines seront sans doute
exposées dans les musées du Caire une
belle réussite même si l'archéologue ne
peut s'empêcher de continuer à rêver de
découvrir un jour une tombe intacte
pour nous c'est très important si un
jour on trouve une tombe à violer voilà
ça serait vraiment le
top du top c'est le maximum qu'on puisse
espérer mais bon ça peut arriver c'est
pas obligé
dernière précaution avant de quitter la
fouille
va-t-il fait sceller le puit avec des
portes blindées faites sur mesure
de quoi empêcher les voleurs de payer
ses trésors
voilà ça ferme bien
[Musique]
loin du tourisme de masse le Nil offre
une parenthèse hors du temps
voici le Soudan l'unique bateau à vapeur
qui navigue sur le fleuve
construit en 1921 il appartient
aujourd'hui à un voyage East français
qui propose des croisières de luxe
67 membres d'équipage pour seulement 23
cabines un service haut de gamme
supervisé dans le moindre détail par
Amir le directeur du bateau
malgré la crise qui touche l'industrie
touristique la compagnie d'Amir n'a
jamais cessé de faire naviguer le Soudan
même à perte si nous avons même un seul
client en fait le Croatie les
répétitions de respect de notre lion
c'est ça l'image notre agence de notre
bateau servir beaucoup de fois que le
bateau navigue même de l'oxyde jusqu'à
asseoir avec alcalion de Clio et on fait
le même service
cette semaine il n'y a que 12 passagers
sur le Soudan Amir accueille chacun
d'eux personnellement les derniers
arrivants ce couple de Français Caroline
et son mari Michael
moi et toute mon équipe vont être
toujours disponible toujours à votre
service sur le 24 heures sur 24 heures
dans mon cœur je vous souhaite bon
séjour et très bon croisière merci à
vous à votre santé merci
[Applaudissements]
qui est chargé de d'un passé enfin en
tout cas ça a été très très bien arrangé
et puis c'est je sais pas c'est un peu
mythique quoi
Caroline et Michael sont venus se
plonger dans l'atmosphère des débuts du
tourisme en Égypte à l'époque d'Agatha
Christie la reine du polar a d'ailleurs
voyagé sur le Soudan en 1933 une
croisière qui l’inspira pour son roman
mort sur le Nils
depuis les cabines n'ont pas beaucoup
changé
oui ça c'est étonnant un lit comme ça
dans une dans une cabine de bateau
il y a un côté authentique différent
décalé mais avec
un certain confort
l'attraction principale du navire se
trouve sur le pont inférieur une salle
des machines ouverte au regard
le mazout a remplacé le charbon mais
toute la mécanique est d'origine avec
les contraintes de l'époque
comme il y a un siècle un machiniste
doit graisser les pistons toutes les
demi-heures pour protéger les éléments
de la casse
[Musique]
je pense qu'on est capable de rester là
une heure juste à regarder le mouvement
c'est un peu addictif comme comme ça ça
serait plus drôle
17h l'heure du thé sur le Soudan à
l'origine c'était un bateau anglais qui
offrait bien sûr un standing impeccable
à ses passagers
ça c'est la cerise sur le gâteau c'est
ce qu'on aime en plus du reste c'est à
dire que le côté un petit peu anglais
avec des petits détails qui vont bien le
personnel qui est extrêmement sympa ça
c'est le plus de la croisière et le plus
de ce bateau en particulier parce que je
pense qu'il y a d'autres bateaux qui
n'offrent pas ça une croisière de rêve
et un prix qui n'a pas baissé depuis la
révolution pour deux on doit être autour
de 5000 euros tout compris pour une
semaine pour une semaine c'est le prix
d'une certaine exception avec du
personnel qui est qualifié avec une
attention avec des petits plus que l'on
vit au niveau du bateau qui semble
expliquer le prix sans problème
les conditions sont exceptionnelles car
le bateau est quasiment vide
une situation qui risque de durer en
raison des menaces qui pèsent encore
aujourd'hui sur l'Égypte et sur ces
trésors
[Musique]